[Musique]
de la musique électro cinq scènes des
milliers de festivaliers et tout cela en
plein coeur des yvelines h à tous
bienvenue à l'électrique parc 2022
[Musique]
ce matin dès l'ouverture des milliers de
fêtards se sont pressés pour participer
à cette 12e édition deux jours de fête
organisée ce samedi 3 et dimanche 4
septembre sur l'île des impressionnistes
cqn j'espère que ça va être bien
normalement c'est le style de musique
que j'aime donc ça va être cool je
connais pas grand monde mais dans tous
les cas ça va être incroyable c'est sûr
ça fait une dizaine d'années que je le
fais donc watch est pas mal oui
allez un festival comme le pks est aussi
adopté un look autour des scènes et dans
les allées des centaines de festivaliers
se sont déguisés pour l'occasion
du plus classique au plus excentriques
on retrouve des hommes grenouilles et
des costumes colorés le bon look c'est
d'abord être est bien dans sa peau moi
j'adore être bien coloré disons j'ai ma
petite casquette rose monty la petite
chemise bien la fleur est disons que
c'est que c'est vraiment être bien dans
sa peau des personnages de séries ou de
films c'est brice de nice voilà bientôt
je vais aller surfer sur la scène
j'attends une vague déjà parce que
là c'est un peu c'est un peu moyen là
des super héros venus pour faire la fête
tu viens déguisés comme tu veux tu t'en
fous des gens mais bien déguisé c'est le
principal moi le déguisement jeu l'a
achetée à la dernière minute j'ai
entendu déguisements j'ai dit aux gars
et en acheter un j'ai été en acheter un
j'ai mis mon slam derrière les filles a
ajouté moi
a ajouté moi voilà au piano je vais le
chercher
voilà on va parler au micro
qui leur déguisement c'est l'envié à
bien même
type alors oui on se connaît pas laisser
l'équipe la famille rapporte quelques
mètres plus loin sur la scène joe l'on
retrouve même un homme arbres c'est son
troisième festival électro achètent ou
pourquoi mon costume moi parce que j'ai
commencé à perdre leur seul ton
compétition il ya quelques années après
c'est resté dans un placard et j'ai fait
une soirée en boîte comme s'asseoir et
militaires seul est sortie ça fait un
carton et je me dis pourquoi pas un
festival et et puis voilà ça fait un
carton si c'est énorme selon moi j'adore
pour ceux qui n'ont pas de costumes
instant de body painting étaient
installés dans le village de l'événement
[Musique]
parce qu'on pouvait pas faire mieux
quand même il est super beau
c'est super agréable à faire avec les
petits pinceaux et tout et c'est un prix
libre donc nickel faut y aller quoi
comme j'avais pas fais un mec maquillage
de où je me suis dit bon allez je vais
faire ça ça va bien peu le reste
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
des couleurs des sourires de la musique
électro dans les yvelines un concept
imaginé par cet homme le célèbre dj
joachim garraud il a créé cet événement
en 2010 moi je ne suis pas pour les
publics qui est spectateur moi je suis
plus de j'aime le public à qu'acteur
donc quand tu viens déguisé quand il ya
un copain que tu es dans un lieu
bucolique comme ça je pense que déjà tu
es dans un état d'esprit festif
même déjà avant d'avoir vu un dj j'ai
toujours mis en avant le fait que la
l'endroit où tu es
impactent directement ton état d'esprit
était là est à sensation de de fête une
fête qui se déroule en pleine journée
contrairement à de nombreux festivals
électro à l'époque joachim garraud
faisait face au scepticisme de nombreux
observateurs le pari risqué a finalement
payé avec plus de 20000 spectateurs sur
les dernières éditions
vous
tout le monde me disait joachim tu vas
te planter parce que la musique
électronique c'est la nuit etc des
lasers et des stroboscopes et ça
commence à 22 heures et ça fini à 5
heures du matin et moi j'ai dit non je
veux je veux que les gens profitent d'un
lieu incroyable avec du soleil et ça n'a
pas de sens de faire ça la nuit dans un
camp dans un parc si tu fais ça dans la
nuit tu fais ça dans un hangar ok mais
la journée dans des arbres magnifiques
l'île des impressionnistes et les airs
elle est fantastique et je suis hyper
fier de ça le concept attire de nombreux
dj sont plusieurs centaines d'artistes à
s'être produit dans les mines de plus au
lancement de l'événement pour cette
édition 2022 on trouve des dj français
connus ou en devenir mais également des
artistes internationaux comme lily
palmer
[Musique]
une djette allemande qui compte plus de
1 million d'abonnés sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui s'est produite ce jour là
devant des milliers de spectateurs
à
dans la foule on retrouve une nouvelle
fois notre homme arbres julien il est
venu devant la scène jaune pour faire la
fête devant l'artiste
tuquoi et c'est toujours un bonheur
c'est excellent
il
[Musique]
julien qui a continué à faire fureur
avec son costume atypique
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu la star aujourd'hui
at-on souvent vos actes j'ai bien
l'impression
si julien déjà des souvenirs plein la
tête avec 7 pk 2022 d'autres n'ont pas
hésité à se faire un souvenir permanent
ce festivaliers s'est fait tatouer le
nom de l'événement juste avant de
participer à l'électrique park 10h je me
suis dit allez pourquoi pas profiter du
moment qu'on me gravé en moi un des
meilleurs moments de ma vie que l'on va
parler comme ça quand je traduis un coup
comme chaque année ce festival y est
aiguisée et présent sur la scène rouge
le lieu propose de l'électro hardcore
magnifique magnifique dumonceau ça
tabasse mais vraiment c'est l'air l'on
pense à ramon était ce qu'on veut dans
son menu c'est que pour ça que pour la
cdjp la meilleure vraiment au top cette
scène est l'une des préférées des
aficionados de l'électro chaque année
ils viennent en nombre devant les
artistes
[Musique]
beaucoup
la bonne hardcore et j'aime beaucoup
parce que ils font pas que du hard ils
font des pauses comme ça on veut se
reprendre notre souffle et c'est très
mélodieux donc c'est cool d'avoir aidé
la mélodie et huard de gucht avait dévié
[Musique]
en
fin d'après-midi le duo de dj nekoé
maissouille se produit sur cette scène
dans une ambiance électrique
[Musique]
ça me plaît pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr que ça fait pas de mal mais
c'est bonne ambiance
la performance dure plus d'une heure
quelques minutes après leur set le
couple revient sur l'événement je suis
pas encore remis là c'est à vous que
c'est un peu trop frais on était vrai
c'était vraiment incroyable vraiment le
public
vraiment on l'a pris à partie tu vois
cette espèce d'ambiance française qu'on
retrouve nulle part ailleurs
c'était magique vraiment tu paies sont
un peu déteint dé réaliser comme
l'espace fait ce coup le public est
vraiment incroyable et les shows il est
vraiment facile pour l'interaction c'est
vraiment plaisir des jets en france
toujours toujours toujours toujours
plaisir parce que le public aime le
moine
[Musique]
chopin les publics et chant patate c'est
vraiment
il est temps de prendre un peu de
hauteur parmi les activités proposées à
l'électrique park festival le saut à
l'élastique
une grue et une nacelle comme point de
départ à 50 mètres de hauteur nos
courageux du jour se nomme bayane et
charlie
mais beaucoup trop bien beaucoup trop
bien pour être ici
j'ai pas accepté j'ai choisi de le faire
mais c'est surtout pour la vue bien sûr
je suis chaud je suis toujours chaud ni
trop court est je trouve ombrage à sa
non je suis trop con non non c'est moi
qui l'ait décidé mais j'ai trop peur
pour tenter d'oublier la peur une
superbe vue là haut sur l'île des
impressionnistes et sur la scène avant
de s'élancer dans le vide
[Musique]
en temps
il y a
pour les réservations
[Musique]
jusqu'au moment où je lâche prise et où
et où tu sais que tu tombes tu as
vraiment l'impression que t'es pas
vraiment en train de le faire c'est
vraiment monter et sinon c'était
incroyable entre la vue
o la sensation incroyable tu trembles je
trouve
quand même content de l'avant ouais
ouais ouais ouais j'suis content d'avoir
fait ouais parce que georges l'offre est
qu'une fois alors vécu tu vois là je les
fais je vais plus jamais tu es mort
alors que certains s'amusent sur
l'électrique parc d'autres sont là pour
les films et environ 30 médias étaient
accrédités pour cette douzième édition
depuis une dizaine d'années in ardeurs
style parcourt la france pour promouvoir
la harde musique alors le problème c'est
pas mal d'interviews et aussi couvrir à
travers un blog voilà on fait un résumé
de l'événement à travers un blog donc
j'ai beaucoup d'interviews d'artistes
hollandais et français qui sont là
pendant les deux jours 70 fait partie
des moments clés de l'année pour le
média avec des festivals organisés sur
tous les week-ends du mois toute
l'équipe est sur le pont pour fournir du
contenu auprès de 9000 abonnés cumulées
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est un
rendez-vous comme immanquable quand même
pour tous les fans de musique
électronique ça fait à peu près trois
quatre ans que le festival électrique
par qui s'intéressent à l'art de musique
pour nous la présence elle est elle
obligatoire parce qu'ils les artistes
qui viennent très peu en france donc
c'est toujours l'occasion de les croiser
de discuter avec eux de les interviewer
de couvrir l'événement et surtout d'en
faire la promotion pour ne pas qu'il y
ait des fans de hard qui qui qui ratent
des événements in ardeurs style restera
sur les deux jours d'événements à chatou
avant de partir à nantes la semaine
suivante pour un autre festival
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la nuit tombe sur cette première journée
de l'électrique parc le réalisateur
quentin dupieux alias mr oizo prend les
commandes des platines de la yellow
stage
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là l'ambiance bat son
plein également sur les autres scènes du
festival
[Musique]
c'est à ce moment là que nous retrouvons
notre homme arbres dans la foule après
une journée bien chargée la fatigue se
fait ressentir le costume commence à
peser
mais la motivation est toujours là bas
ça pue ça commence à pékin
si j'en ai les motions ont pas toujours
toujours la joie toujours m'éclate
la cellule
son déguisement pour le moins originale
a fait fureur et notre star du jour se
prennent même à l'exercice du sel fille
et
qu'est ce que tu attends maintenant
georges team seront
effectivement milieu de soirée il est
temps pour joachim garraud de troquer sa
casquette de producteur pour celle de dj
et se produira lors de trois sets du
festival
[Musique]
à
ge a joué sur la yellow ce soir à 21h15
avec joachim garraud space invaders en
bac techno
et je fais quarante minutes à peu près
et après j'arrête quand j'arrête après
j'accueille sur celle de laurentiis qui
est une productrice chanteuse et tous
les deux ont fait un groupe qui
s'appelle avoriaz et là on va faire un
truc plus futur rêve chanter un peu plus
mélodique un peu plus féminin masculin
pas que techno
[Musique]
et
dimanche dimanche je vais remplacer un
artiste qui n'a pas pu venir qui est
bloqué en russie qui est reason et donc
je vais remplacer je vais jouer dimanche
soir sur la black et là je vais me faire
plaisir je vais faire je vais improviser
un set on va
[Musique]
pour clôturer la journée de samedi
martin solveig le dj aux nombreux tubes
a choisi l'électrique pas pour sa
dernière date de l'année avant de se
consacrer à la préparation de son
prochain album qui sortira en 2023
[Musique]
une première journée terminée et réussi
les festivités se poursuivront le
lendemain pour cette douzième édition
l'électrique parc a attiré 27 mille
festivaliers sur l'île des
impressionnistes de chatou le rendez
vous est déjà pris pour l'année
prochaine
[Musique]
art